[Music]
there are other people why should you be
the only one involved but I am involved
we are all involved though he starred in
only three films in the 1950s James Dean
remains a Hollywood legend Dean's life
was cut short by a car crash in 1955
now movie makers are using computer
technology to bring him back in a new
role this week a production company
announced it purchased the rights to use
Dean's image from the late actor's
family their plan is to use a mixture of
old film footage and photos to create a
digital Dean to co-star in a new film
called
finding Jack another actor will provide
the characters voice and body reactions
to the announcements haven't exactly
been positive it seems like actors in
particular are not too enthused with the
idea that is now dawning on them that
after they pass away they may be brought
back to play roles they might not have
otherwise agreed to do it's not the
first time filmmakers have tried to
bring a dead actor to life on screen in
1955 Bela Lugosi died before finishing
ed woods infamous plan 9 from outer
space would cast another actor who
finished Lugosi scenes hidden by a cape
in 2000 Gladiator co-star Oliver Reeves
died of a heart attack while filming in
Malta director Ridley Scott brought in a
body double and a CGI team to create a
mask of Reed's face with much of the two
minutes of footage shot in the shadows
it seems you're the one new freedom and
in rogue one a Star Wars story Disney
use CGI to bring Peter Cushing back to
life to a mixed reception prepare for
the jump to hyperspace and inform lord
Vader
at times it looked a little unreal it
didn't the illusion wasn't convincing
can you make them suspend disbelief and
make them believe that this dead person
is somehow still performing and still
acting that's a very tall order
now with rapidly evolving technology
could resurrecting stars of the past see
a much larger
part of her film going future regardless
of what happens with finding Jack I
think we all need to accept the fact
that this is the future what if you
could make a new Star Wars with the
digital versions of all the original
characters not just Carrie Fisher what
if you could make a sequel to Casablanca
with Humphrey Bogart and Ingrid Bergman
I think this is the start of perhaps a
slightly ghoulish new trend we can all
just stay home next weekend they're
gonna CGI oh sorry we did reach out to
the production company by the way we did
not hear back from them so I mean there
is the question about whether this movie
actually gets made or what do people
want to see it get made well back in the
1980s there was a movie called the
looker with Susan Day you remember her
and it was about how computer animation
or something like it could showcase all
of us and take over